[Musique]
bonjour bonjour à tous bon jour à tout
je vous souhaite un bon après midi à
notre compagnie je vous souhaite surtout
la bienvenue sur tf1 jeudi surtout parce
qu'aujourd'hui c'est un jour un peu
particulier vous avez l'habitude du
genre particulier sur tf1 7 cette saison
si j'ose dire parce que le 20 décembre
la couleur et puis demain si le premier
anniversaire est aujourd'hui le premier
lundi après midi des ptf on continue on
continue ça veut dire qu' il n'y aura
plus de trous entre la fin du journal de
13h et 18h 15 il y aura quatre heures 45
démission et puis je vous ferai le
sommaire détaillé tout à l'heure mais
avant cela je voudrais vous dire que je
ne présenterai pas cet après midi c'est
lundi après-midi tout seul je serai en
compagnie d'ariane
bonjour je vous rejoins mesdames
aujourd'hui de modèle bonjour messieurs
et bien en effet vous venez de découvrir
les deux visages de vos compagnons du
lundi puisque tous les lundis nous
serons ensemble pour vous faire passer
quatre heures et demie il a environ avec
beaucoup via co2 rubrique de nous voir
leur au total 1 mais aujourd'hui ce que
je voulais vous dire c'est que nous pour
nous c'est un jour de fête sont un petit
peu ému mais c'est un jour de fête et
tout de suite avant de me garder trop
longtemps place de la musique place à la
fête avec précisément un groupe
d'amérique latine qui sait ce que fais
tu veux dire
[Musique]